pour toi ça va être très simple
franchement c'est plus trop simple tu
vas avoir une minute pour trouver une
personne et danser avec elle sur un
poteau mais de façon très sexy ah oui un
poteau dans la rue ok ok
[Applaudissements]
c'est que c'est l'argent de côté j'adore
désir c'est beaucoup j'ai étudié à
barbecue je lui dis attention attention
tu joues avec qui maintenant bouder
qu'est ce que je dois faire moi alors
c'est très simple et vite le deuxième
poteau bravo c'est surtout pas peu dire
un mot tu vas devoir est là et tu vas
pas la cote et prendre des gens c'est
très simple tu vas voir une minute pour
trouver une personne en voitures allait
lui offrir des fleurs et demander un
petit bisou en retour enfin c'est quoi
la limite tu vas jouer pour un casque de
réalité virtuelle
j'ai pas le filet trois fois oui bah tu
en voilà
et donc j'arrête une voiture n'importe
laquelle la face c'est le bijou avec
laure goudiard ses pancartes
mais regarde pas échapper normalement
derby n'a volé la vedette et philippe
risoli 10e au portugal elle sait pas qui
l'a volée d'humour mais j'ai pas envie
de me trouver
la deuxième partie on y va bouder alors
oui pas de voiture à temps de faire sa
voiture avait l'habitude de se déplacer
à bourg-madame arrive et on gagne sa
cause en bus
c'est pourtant à messi ne la regarde
notre patrie la terre sortir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait gagner un cousin
tu as pas d un casque de réalité
virtuelle avec teacheo juin voilà je
vais donner le défi à valérie valérie
c'est très simple vous allez devoir
partir ah bon vous allez avoir
exactement un mois pour trouver notre
attention de toujours me longo bachelot
tranquille des quartiers tranquilles
alors valérie tu vas voir une minute tu
vas jouer on va jouer pour une machine à
café
n'empêche il a cassé la gueule tu vas
voir une minute pour aller faire une
déclaration d'amour un inconnu
d'accord je lui devais de la base m tu
sais faire des déclarations pas de
boulette de taille si vous avec ta gym
ça rime avec je sais pas quoi tu joues à
dakar ok très bien d'accord entre eux
sur le monde s'il est sous le charme
fonds qui disent oui je suis sous le
charme
d'accord il faut qu'il ait ça oui je
suis sous le charme pour pas voilà donc
tu veux gagner deux matches et la caf à
julie c'est parti au niveau auquel cas
pour pas trop quand je suis sur un char
attention
non non le déni que le feu n'est pas
laissée là attention fais attention tu
me fais peur sur la route voilà la
regarde la condition que l'état se
voulait simplement l'adversaire je vous
ai vus régulièrement et je suis aussi
les beaux gosses est en fait un sur
scène je me disais que ben vous aviez
vraiment la tête du content de charme
que il est beau gosse que le plus beau
des couscous est vraiment vous étiez
voilà une petite boulette
non je voulais faire partie à votre tour
vous étiez un mois les camés charme de
cette déclaration parce que vous êtes
sous le charme propose verso est ce que
je ferai ce que je peux rattraper la
métaphore avec un slot un petit seront
allés way
il s'appelle jonathan il n'est pas du
tout sinon on voit que ça paie chaud
dans l'émission j'ai lâché pour ses
chutes
[Applaudissements]
et
49 oh là là tout va bien mais j'étais
sorti il était très sympathique très
sympa les rites attentive et leïla
bekhti fait ou pas juju moyens il peut
le temps qui le devient quand même le
mégawattheure le tablier valeur jeudi à
cannes comme on dit du bébé je suis tout
temps on en 2018 que jack begaud gros
c'est pas tant la halle à [ __ ] alors
là attention avec qui tu veux jouer
maintenant
[Musique]
maxime galy sylvie testud maxime des
gens voient en débit bowling et surtout
un maxi single we win a real et ne le
fais confiance à mes macs film alors
maxime jeudi c'est très simple vous
allez avoir
vous avez joué avec maxime gagny pour
une console de jeu portable ou là tu vas
voir une minute pour trouver une
personne lui demander son prénom et le
crier de plaisir comme si vous faisiez
l'amour avec lui ouais d'accord si
d'accord
madame away with puisse vous demander
votre prénom alala ici malisse et marie
cécile et ceci au mieux mon cas la mia
marie-cécile je t'aime d'accord darfour
d'amour ça compte a demandé ce qu'il a
qui seraient détenus dans l'instant
présent
vas-y tu veux faire quoi dès que tu
faisais l'amour c'est gratuit
ricoh n'est pas un gars qui va te dire
maxime tu m'écoutes oui si et simule un
orgasme di feno toi avec marie cécile
non marie-cécile conduit un des deux
siciles ac c'est bien médaille or may
récession et non mais reflètent le goût
parce que je trouve que franchement
ville ou quoi babylone c'est si tu as
commencé machine tu peux faire la même
chose
cécile à ottawa demandait de chanter à
dorval
maryse ceci va bien